Yeah, if we just only focus on him touching his nose, we'll never
be able to move forward. Okay. >> Faith attack. I was trying
to think about it. I don't even know what your politics are to
be honest. I I I don't know. I have no sense of if you're like
>> Hutch and Willie finally aligning on something. Willie
doesn't know either. Oh my god. >> Because I don't really
know what my >> You can't make it up. You literally can't
make it up. Okay. >> I honestly I think I'm running like
an IQ of like a B+ maybe like an 88% or something. I'm not I'm
not that smart, >> bro. There's no way that Willie like
literally just was like, "Hold on, let me go re-watch the video
so I can understand the arguments I was making." There's no shot
that that's what that debate is.
>> I got it. >> No, for sure. But like, >> so
Hutch talked to Willie Mack about some of this stuff earlier
as well. Okay. Some of his fears about doxing were fueled in
this combo with Willie Mack. This was, I believe, shortly after
the Willie Mack piece on Bad Empanada.
He he came on to Hutch's stream. me talk to Hutch and they talk
about doxing what they think is like uh you know the responsibility
of creators who
who do some of this stuff who like uh who are engaging and apparently
need to lower the temperature. All right, give me a
>> Yeah. Well, tell me about yourself because I don't know
much about like your background here and probably a lot of people
in my audience don't know either. So, how did you get started
on YouTube and how has your content changed and evolved over
the years? Yeah, I mean, I don't think it it's really changed
that much other than the longer you do something, you get better.
All I All I do is cover YouTube drama and like uh the different
zany characters online and the mess that the messes they end
up getting themselves into. And um a lot of people like I feel
like I mean they've always done this but specifically with this
group um if they're strong in their political believing um like
leaning I mean um they always end up labeling me as like the
opposite thing. Like when I was going after Andrew Tate or Fresh
and Fit or any of those guys, their whole thing was like Willy's
clearly a blue hill bluehaired they them liberal. Yeah. You >> Okay.
Um, dude, Willie spent a lot of time going after Andrew Tate
and Fresh and Fit. >> So, I mean, this is more like par
for the course stuff. Um, except for the doxing, which is just
like insane, you know, obviously.
>> Yeah. So, >> it's funnier now that like the wedding's
over, but at the time that really sucked ass and was not uh all
that all that >> Well, I want to get into that in just
a minute, but I want to I want to ask you more about So, like
like what year did you start doing the YouTube stuff? Like how
long did it take your channel to start picking up? Was there
a particular topic that you covered where you started to see
more? >> God, Willie wants to talk about the video and
Hutch is Hutch is on interview RZ. Hutch wrote down some questions
and he hasn't like moved forward with Willie. Willie just like
moved the topic forward onto something substantial and Hutch
is like, "Yeah."
So anyway, how did you start your channel, man? Did you like
start on a specific topic or something? Did you like did you
find a did you start on a specific well how how' you what was
the history like? It's like bro he just moved the topic forward.
Could you react
>> growth on your channel? Like how did you blow up? >> I
mean I always enjoy >> Yeah, obviously Jacob. Yeah, we
all I at least tried very hard to keep any of his information
from being stated anywhere on any of my platforms in chat. anywhere
>> enjoyed like doing YouTube, but like back in the day
like at least it seemed like to me like nobody made money on
YouTube or or if people did it was like very rare. Um, so it
wasn't until suddenly like I got back from college and I end
up watching like a couple of drama videos where I was like, man,
this is like really easy. The these videos that people are are
watching that are getting like hundreds of thousands of views
are not very good. So, what if I covered it and I just tried
to be like really entertaining and just like quickwitted about
the whole thing and like laughed at the whole thing and it was
like immediately like I think >> then he found out he couldn't
do that. So, he asked Nicholas Yuro for help writing scripts.
Okay, >> that video got like 200,000 views. >> What
was the first >> dude? Uh oh. Look,
people talking I look at the chat and they're talking about me
and Quean.
Amazing. J is probably going to rage watch this for six hours.
pin something about swatting being bad. Lol.
This guy is a fat. Also, I had this in my docket from before.
Didn't watch it. Literally didn't watch it at all. This is from
August 12th. I actually just skipped it. Uh, ask him about Queen
and all the bad things Quimman does.
>> First video on. Do you remember the the
>> Yeah. Yeah. It was by a guy named uh Anthony Fantano.
>> He made a video on a guy named Behind the Meme. And
the whole con, this concept was insane to me at the time. The
whole concept was the behind the meme guy is like the memes by
explaining them. And this was like a huge a huge problem that
needed to be solved. >> I've had some stop memes from being
explained. Dude,
>> I've had some runins with Needle Drop as of late. Um,
not not >> I don't really know anything about >> No,
Dmer Dumer does not write for Willie. Oh. Oh, apparently Anthony
Fentanto is like living these guys head. >> But it was
a very bizarre video to me. >> He's very scoldy these days.
And uh but there was something >> scoldy back then, bro.
He was literally like don't explain the Crash Bandicoot wo meme,
>> right?
You're the internet, dude.
>> Well, he had something recent that happened to him where
people had DJ Academics, is that the guy's name? Had unearthed
old videos of Needle Drop making edgy jokes or something like
that. And I feel like in those situations, even if that person,
in this case, Needle Drop is super scoldy, like >> I don't
care about their comments on Anthony Fantano. >> Yeah.
Yeah. And then he was also on a podcast where somebody had made
a joke, I think, about
Trayvon Martin and then
>> Yeah. I I don't know if you guys know this. Hutch touches
his nose approximately like eight times per minute. Okay. Yeah.
If we just only focus on him touching his nose, we'll never be
able to move forward. Okay. faith attacking him. So, like even
though I think he does bad behavior, like this needle drop person,
>> like I've seen some videos on him that were pretty good.
Like that guy I don't think is like the greatest dude ever. Um,
look, I think a problem is when you go ahead and you walk around
and you do like the holier than doubt thing and you get at people
for their language
>> comes back to bite you and people dig up stuff on you
like you got you should be aware of that. >> Yeah. you
know, you put yourself >> I don't really like to go do
the whole like your joke was too edgy criticism because it's
just it's it's stupid because we've all said edgy jokes. We've
all laughed at something we probably shouldn't have. >> Yeah,
for sure. >> Makes sense.
>> So, you were doing the drama stuff, but then at some
point it kind of started to intersect with politics. It just
it feels like a lot of conversations that happen online are downstream
from politics these days. Was that a conscious choice that you
made to to to go into politics or did just did it end up that
way? The other thing too is like I was trying to think about
it. I don't even know what your politics are to be honest. I
I I don't know. I have no sense of if you're like
>> are you you don't know what his politics are? Wow. Hutch
and Willie finally aligning on something. Willie doesn't know
either. Oh my god. >> Because I don't really know what
my uh >> You can't make it up. You literally can't make
it up. Okay.
I did not pre-watch. I've never seen I've never seen this part
of the the argument before. I I literally just watched one part
on Queen's stream. I asked him for like a time stamp on this
because I remember I was going to cover it before.
Um but that's not even this part. It's going to be his part about
lowering the temperature. But we all know that Willie has no
idea what his politics are. Why do people watch this guy? Um
because he's like their current useful He's their current golem.
Okay.
There's no God, I'm so I'm so like poisoned on on right now.
It's like whatever golem you find to make like the terrible arguments
you don't want to make, you have to show unc uncritical unconditional
support for them at all times,
right? So you find a golem and you you literally you prop them
up and you show uncritical unconditional support for them and
you let them say all the things that you don't want to say. Okay,
he'll he's like the vanguard. He's out in front. Okay, he's the
actual vanguard, tip of the spear. He comes in, he makes all
of the totally arguments and then other people can come in and
go, "Well, like maybe he took it too far, but like don't you
think he kind of has a point here? Don't you think he kind of
has a point there?"
That's what P that's what Putch that's what Hutch is doing for
everybody. Okay, Hutch is tip of the spear number one golem.
That's what he's doing right now. Not just on Israel, by the
way. I say golem because it happens to be overlap with the Zionist
stuff, but that is his job right now is to basically be way out
in front, be saying the things and then other people can come
in, right? We saw this with the chorus of stuff. If Hutch comes
out and he just immediately amplifies any propaganda he can.
He just grabs whatever thread he can to talk about how lefties
are bad. Then people could come in behind him and go, "Well,
maybe it's like not all bad, but like don't you know, like did
Taylor Ren say anything positive about Chorus? Did she say anything
positive about liberals? see anything nice?
It's like, okay, I
that's not what this is about. That's not what it's about at
all. She's not She's not required to say something nice about
you. Shut up. >> Sorry. You know, I'm not exactly like
a very politically knowledgeable person. And I think if people
want to go ahead and get like political opinions, they probably
should go to people that are a lot smarter than me. You know,
I feel like I kind of stick to like when it comes to my >> That's
why I seek my political opinions from the cashier at McDonald's.
I just had to find somebody smarter than Willie. I happened to
be in line when he said this the first time. Okay. And I was
like, "Hey, what do you think about Israel Palestine?" >> The
content is like, you know, when it comes to cover >> Yeah.
No, I I want a Coke Zero. No ice in the Coke Zero, please. Uh,
but yeah, Israel Palestine thoughts >> covering politics
more. It's like it's not really I'm covering politics. It's more
I'm covering people that cover politics cuz the internet's grown
up since I first started. When I first started doing YouTube,
it was like very childish drama. Like it was like Idubbbz rolling
around in the dirt and like Leafy uh playing like CS GO or whatever,
right? Like like the drama was very
That audience has grown up and now it turns out politics has
like the best drama. Like these people are these people are grandchildren,
dude. It's
So you So like you've had running, >> dude. Willie like
wants to be Auggie so badly, but he also took a side. Like I
believe Auggie when he says, "I want to laugh at everybody."
Because Auggie will piss people off laughing at someone, right?
Like he's uh he's like he's just gonna chaotically laugh at a
bunch of different people and he'll pick people off. And Willie
wants to be like Auggie. Willie wants to be the guy who just
laughs at everybody. He's above it. But then he just takes a
side entirely. Like he's just 100% on one side only. And he's
like, "Guys, guys,
everybody's funny. Everybody's funny." >> With all kinds
of various different communities. I mean, I was communic I don't know
if I'm going to bias I'm not I I don't know if I'm going to bias
your answer on this question, but I was just telling my audience
a little while ago that I've >> I've I've kind of rolled
around in the mud with various toxic communities and just anecdotally
my experience recently with sparring with I call them black pill
lefties. They're just like very kind of it's like a very kind
of unhinged kind of leftwing politics.
Um, for me, for me that's been for sure the most like aggressive,
hostile, deranged, like crowd. Like even more so than MAGA, even
more so than like Call of Duty F. >> Dude, I I just can't
wait. Okay,
one quick stopover we could do
is I believe Hutch went on Sitch and Adam and Hutch argued with
them that it's insane. It's insane to compare even the the most
extreme leftist to MAGA.
I could have sworn this happened, right? And now here he is.
We're we're almost a year after the election and he's here like
I don't even know if he knows it. He's here like guys, Adam was
right all along. The the socialists, they actually are the worst
part. Okay, they actually are the worst. Adam friend was correct
about everything. I'm entirely on Adam's side now. He'll never
say it like that, but that's 100% the position he's drifted into
at this point.
Right. Adam's whole point is the socialists are ruining they're
they're like directing America. They're ruining America. If they
ever get power, it'll be the end of America. That's Adam's argument
the whole time. And Hutch has just totally picked that up and
he's like, "Oh, you know what? This is nice." And then Pisco,
think of how this looks for Pisco, okay? Just empathize with
Pisco. He has to sit there and listen to his specify all of Adam's
opinion opinions and go, "Yeah, Hutch is my boy." Yeah, I realize
that I've I've absolutely like put my knee down on Adam's neck
for having these opinions, but you know, Hutch is my boy. I don't
have to I'm not going to quite go as hard on Hutch, but because
Hutch is my boy, but like Yeah, he's just saying the exact things
Adam was saying that I totally tried to like kill that guy for
100%.
But Hutch is my boy. Yeah, he's like But he's my boy. He's like
the boy who we accidentally like left in the bathtub and he was
deprived of oxygen for like 4 minutes as like a 6-month-old.
But he's my boy. >> Fans and other like video game fandoms.
Um have you had different experiences
kind of sparring with different communities that have like different
political leanings? What's what's been your experience so far?
cuz I assume it things ratcheted up for you when you started
to take a like a pro ethan kind of position
because the same thing happened to me as soon as I started saying
well wait a second I actually think Ethan is making some really
good points here and I think it's crazy that CPS was called that's
when I started getting like I just said all I said this is like
how do you not how do you make fun of Hassan ever for doing the
guys I just want universal healthcare that's all I just want
universal healthcare guys all Hutch said was guys isn't it kind
of weird to call CPS and people were starting to dox him immediately.
Guys, isn't it weird to like call CPS on someone and they're
like, "Oh, get this guy's address right now. Get get his address
now." Apparently, all I said was, you know, three skulls. Why
not? What skull? Three skulls? Why not one? Two skulls? Oh, it's
two skulls. Why not one? And they they doxed me. It's crazy,
>> Like really heavily attacked by these people. Um, did
you have a similar situation there? >> I mean, I was on
the Hassan like Hassan is a
hypocrite covering the news thing for like a long time before
Ethan, you know? So, I I honestly feel like these
uh genres on YouTube,
when you criticize the people, whether it's Andrew Tate or like
Myin or Sneo, their response a lot of the time is pretty similar
or Hassan or Bosch or whatever, right? Like I feel like um it
always turns into like deflect, make up a nickname for the guy
like uh call them slap or call them stupid or call them a liberal
or call
right? Like whatever it is and just try and discredit like that
that's always the game plan. Um I personally feel like yeah,
when I covered Ethan, it like suddenly like brought in bad empanada
because he's obviously been platformed by Hassan.
And um the minute I turned and I criticized that guy, like I
I shouldn't be shocked at all when I turn around when I get doxed,
right?
>> Well, it's
it it escalates to these like very realworld consequences. So,
>> wait, did he hold on?
>> There's no way he >> brought in bad empanada because
he's obviously been platformed by Hassan.
And um the minute I turned and I criticized that guy, like I
I shouldn't be shocked at all when I turn around when I get doxed,
right? >> Wait, is he basically just blaming it on bad
air? Is he like acknowledging reality there? Wait, what? How
do you make the video he made and then come out and just say
that after?
What? Guys, I I guess you know I did around with bad empanada.
I guess I shouldn't be surprised. But then he blames a different
group entirely for his doxing.
Well, it's
it it escalates to these like very realworld consequences. So,
for for these people when Ethan had CPS called on him, it was
like a running joke. Um I was I was just telling >> it
was not a running joke at first. In fact, a lot of people were
like, "You know what? You know what? That's really up. That's
beyond the pale. CPS got called. That's beyond the pale. That's
crazy." And then you know what happened? There was never any
acknowledgement that that was a widely understood and acknowledged
perspective even in the leftist people. It was a widely acknowledged
and appreciated perspective, right? And because it just kept
getting thrown in people's faces after 3 months, after 6 months,
after 9 months, right, we started going, "Oh, you know what?"
or sorry, maybe not 9 months yet cuz it might have been in February,
but after 3 months or 6 months, it's like, you know what it is?
You stop throwing that in my face. Like, like that's a reason
we all have to stop, okay? Just stop. Ethan sub was calling DHS
and FBI on Hassan. It's just it's so stupid. Hassan literally
called it out. He he criticized it harshly immediately and it
doesn't matter. It'll still be held against him. It'll still
be held against everybody on that side, right? It doesn't matter.
And because it doesn't matter because nobody wants to slow down
and go, "Oh, maybe there are some like human people over here
and we could actually talk to them." Nobody wants to do that,
right? It just all keeps going all the time. Oh, whoops. Unpin
that.
It just it just keeps going forever and ever. But like I don't
think there was a wide I don't think the wide response to CPS
getting called from most people was huh loser. I don't think
it was I think there was some some pretty you know
some like people who had had that opinion immediately. One of
them was bad empanada. Bad empata wanted to joke about that immediately
right but after months it's like dude
we need to we need to stop now. We need to stop doing just the
CPS thing over and over and over and over again. in my chat a
minute ago. Like as soon as that happened, every single one of
those
>> Yeah. Exactly. Ki 64 has got it right. Yeah. Exactly.
Like at some point it starts to feel stupid to even to even sit
there and try to grant some humanity to the other side, try to
be nice. It starts to feel dumb. Like I feel like a I feel like
a total for banning everybody who is trying to say, "Oh, you
should talk about Will Matt. Willie Matt's info is out there.
Oh, did you see Willie Mack got doxed? I I ban those people.
I removed the messages from chat. I said, "If you talk about
anybody's public, private information getting published, I'll
ban you, right?" And then Willie goes on Twitter and accuses
me of doxing him. What the was the point of doing any of that?
I try to be a human to of trying to be a human to the guy. Like,
I'm probably going to keep doing it, but at some point it's like
I understand everybody who is way too black on that to ever grant
that charity to the other side ever cuz it doesn't matter. It
doesn't matter what you do, right? they're still going to blame
you for the exact thing that you you disavowed or said you don't
support. So like at some point, I don't know, I have my principles.
I'll sit here getting because I have principles for the rest
of time, but at some point like other people will believe them.
Other people will believe I don't have those principles just
based on lies. And I don't know, I don't know what happens at
that point. Okay. >> Should have gone live or posted a
video or posted a tweet or an Instagram post or something, >> you
know, telling their audience like, "Look, we don't agree with
him. We think this is bad, but this is obviously escalated to
a degree that is um unacceptable. And >> I think he deserves
it, >> right? That's the point. Yeah, it's that's the joke.
>> It's unhinged. Like I've never seen like it get this
far.
>> Like seriously, like it should be just entirely unacceptable.
Like I don't know
>> Forget the apology to Queen. I don't give a [__]
about that guy. Well, he needs to apologize to me and say that
he totally made that up and he's a complete Oh, but that's like
not even the first time he's totally made something up about
me and tried to propagate it. He was he was totally sucking Destiny's
and repeating everything that guy said for weeks. Like one crying
phone call to the cops makes up for that. No, it doesn't.
>> The the answer is for platforming or like exciting a
community who's doing the doxing or doing the the CPS calls,
whatever we're going to call it. Um but it it's just blows my
mind like so many people are okay with it. Like I swear to God,
dude, 5 years ago covering drama, if you just corrected people
and were like, "This is the truth." That person would get obliterated
every time. The person who's lying would get obliterated almost
every time. Every year we've slipped closer into the future.
Every every following year, it's just become like um completely
okay to lie. And not just from the streamer's perspective or
the the creators perspective, but from the viewers perspective.
Like viewers are okay with it, too. They know it. They got to
see it. They're just fine with it. >> It's for like greater
cause. >> Well, I think it's like a mixed bag. So, there's
going to be like the >> I don't think so. It's sort of
getting normalized cuz a bunch of people I think a bunch of creators,
okay,
have
have realized that their audiences are actually like brain damaged
and don't hold them responsible for anything. And that if even
if they do this, like this is definitely what Destiny realized,
right? I I don't think you could have realized this any harder
than when you basically admit to having child and people are
like, "Yeah, not even child can make me stop watching this guy."
Right? Once you've once you've hit that level, it's like
how do you how do you try to hold yourself like do we even
I don't know, man. I'm like so lost at that point. It's the Homelander
meme. It is the Homelander meme. Yeah. All right.
Everybody's just clapping for you,
It is a perfect usage of the Homelander meme. Let's go.
Uh,
but the rest of like most normal people, most intelligent like
people you'd care about the opinions of online, nobody's okay
with doxing. Well, yeah, I would I would say that basically you
kind of throw yourself outside of the group who of outside of
the group where people's opinions are like reasonable or should
be respected if you're just okay with doxing people based on
innuendo. Yeah. Anyway, creators themselves I I can't stand this
uh this will guy. >> They know it. They got to see it.
They're just fine with it. It's for like greater cause. >> Well,
I think it's like a mixed bag. So, there's going to be like the
creators themselves, they know they're lying. So, like when Noah
and E and Hassan joke about you being controlled opposition or
perhaps like controlled by MSAD or that your wife is a IDF soldier
or something, they know that's a lie. And I think >> the
IDF went, you know what? Let's go ahead and move this threeyear-old
girl to the US because in 20 years she's gonna she's gonna we
got to control the media that Willie Mac Show puts out. Dude,
it was a five head game, dude. Well, they're
>> there's like there's like four people or five people
here who are like totally fine with uh with like insane stakes
and none of those people are respectable. Like none of those
people are respectable at all. It's not not insane stakes, insane
tactics being used against like anybody who disagrees with them.
And none of those people are worthy of respect. And Willie tried
to basically sweep for and respect one of the people doing it
and he got what was coming to him, right? Like he got a wakeup
call.
The same thing Hutch is sowing about here, right? Destiny did
that jokingly. I would assume most people did it jokingly. I
have who uh you know all the names. Uh Desty did it jokingly.
I'm sure the people who Hutch is so about did it jokingly, right?
I know I made joking IDF jokes. It's just a funny joke. It's
a funny meme. Okay. IDF honeypotss. That's funny. >> There
could be something there. I mean, you don't know. Like, you don't
know. They they they play the long game. >> No, but they
play the long game. So, you don't know. It's possible. I guess
it's not a 0% chance. >> We got no chance that this is
But now that we're married, it's great cuz I can like use all
the weather machines and >> they got you. They got They
got their They got their hooks into you, bud. There's no >> control
what Fox News says. It's It's great. It's amazing. I mean, but
but so so
I do think that there's a lot. >> Wait, you lay down with
dogs, you reap the whirlwind. Private Huff, that's not the saying.
You lay down with dogs, you reap the It's you
is it you sew the wind. If you sew the wind, reap the whirlwind.
Sew the wind, reap the whirlwind, right? As in you, you start
like you start blowing down the little piggy's houses.
Don't be shocked when the whirlwind comes back at you. Okay.
>> Play the long game, so you don't know. It's possible.
I guess it's not a 0% chance. We got no chance that this is it.
But now that we're married, it's great because I can like use
all the weather machines. And >> they got you. They got
they got their they got their hooks into you, bud. >> Oh,
so Willy's allowed to do it. So Willy's allowed to make these
jokes, but we can't. That's
>> control what Fox News says. It's it's great. It's amazing.
I mean, but but so so I do think that there's a lot of them that
lie, but what what ends up happening is that
>> with Fox News, >> the lie gets repeated so often
that their audience >> just uncritically accepted as the
truth. And so I'm sure from now, like from now on, you're going
to get like a lot of people in your replies and comments accusing
you of being manipulated by MSAD or accusing your wife of being
IDF. And uh they they genu a lot of those people genuinely believe
this stuff. Um >> yeah. No, but I I agree with you, dude.
But there's there's entire >> Who who genuinely believes
that? I It's so crazy to me that we'll take bad empanada saying
something is like genuine belief. The guy who lies about literally
everything. Every one of his enemies he lies explicitly about.
Even people aligned with him go, "Yeah, that guy just makes up.
That guy lies all the time." And then sit here, shut the [__]
>> Okay, hold on. I'll let the demon you're doing a great
job with the talking
you got to go thinking. They know what's going on. Keep up the
stick. >> Okay, thank you for the 15. Rabbi Moshiim Liboitz,
thank you very much, Rabbi. Appreciate the 15. Okay, dude. Anyway,
like I was saying, Hassan will sit there and go, "No, no, Badam
Pinata is lying here. He's just making up, right? Everybody calls
Ben and Benata out. They all go, "Yeah, this guy's just lying.
Totally." And Hutch will sit here with a straight face and say,
"Guys, people really believe this stuff. They really believe
that Willy Mack has an IDF bride. They really They really believe
that I that Willie Mack was honeypotted by the IDF."
Come on, man. PPP donut voice just as annoying as the real thing.
That's just Gilbert Godfrey, dude. You ever watch Aladdin? You
like uh Iago the parrot? It's that guy on that. That's objectively
true what you just said. But there is also a >> Oh god.
What did What did Willie say was objectively true? >> Blame
your >> That's not a That's not a good sign for whatever
Hutch just said. Okay. What what you just said that was objectively
true what you just said. >> Lies and comments accusing
you of being
manipulated by MSAD or accusing your wife of being IDF. And uh
they they gen a lot of those people genuinely believe this stuff.
Um >> Yeah. No, but I I agree with you, dude. But there's
there's entirely on that. That's objectively true what you just
said, but there is >> Oh, that a lot of people believe
this stuff. I see. So, yeah, Hutch is saying something totally
[__] and really goes, "Yeah, that's the that's objectively
true what you just said. That's objectively true." Wow. >> There's
also a shocking amount of viewers who are entirely okay with
the lie. Yeah. Like in a way I've never seen before. Like, this
is not normal. It's not exclusive to me. It's just every year
from 2020, like CO broke everybody's brains or something, dude.
Yeah. Every year from 2020, it's just become like more okay.
Like I mean, for [__] sake, dude. Like, we see the
[__] president do this [__] right? Well,
I was just about to say >> fuckingly lying about numbers
or whatever the [__] it is. >> Yeah. I mean,
I I was just about to say I think what I think the way that we
can sort of unpack why this is the >> It's just It's crazy
to go, guys,
the president's lying. Everyone's okay with this now. and not
actually like take into account what people are saying about
you, what like the broad consensus is. Like everybody basically
is allowed to go and say, "Here's one comment that's totally
unhinged and insane
and it doesn't matter that it's got like three likes and 50 views."
That's the prevailing opinion now because it's negative about
me. So, everybody just believes lies about me. It's like, can
you show me like a lot of people getting upvoted somewhere where
they're like sincerely accusing you of this?
I just I don't see it. I really don't see it. why they're just
everyone is just so okay with this kind of lying is because I
think people have watched Donald Trump
uh lie to a degree that we've literally never seen in terms of
like a US politician and face no consequences of of that from
that and then even more they've seen him benefit from that like
they've seen him manipulate his own followers into thinking the
most ridiculous things like windmills cause cancer and blah blah
blah and so they I think a lot of them it is like a it is like
a black pill >> big Willie dropping truth truth nukes honestly
just uh
you want to talk about black pill left whatever this is is black
pilling far more than any leftist accelerationist could possibly
be >> anything that's said >> yeah he thinks that
windmills cause cancer like he said this a thousand times and
he thinks that they whales I mean he's just whatever I mean this
is just one of like thousands of lies that this guy regularly
says but but I think people in in the left-wing spaces they they
saw that he really was able to gain a lot of power by manipulating
his own people in that way. And so now I just think we're living
in kind of like this post-truth era where their I think their
thinking is probably like right. This is just an information
war. Everybody else is doing it. It works and so we're just going
to do it. Yeah.
>> it's through act it's act political activism to uh to
dox my wedding. >> It's practis. Yeah. I mean I wanted
to get into that. >> That's so weird that he's willing
to come on this stream and he's like not actually blaming queen
for it. This would have been right after the video, right? Hold
on. We got any updates on this video yet, by the way? No, no
corrections, no updates at all. >> See here, I saw Nope.
So, four weeks ago, it's right after this, right? Yeah, it's
like a day later, 2 days later. And he's just going to complain
about bad empanada and lefties doxing him. But he blames somebody
entirely different here. He's like, "Oh, it's political practice
to dox me." Now, I guess he could be referring to, you know,
a different instance of doxing, not originating the docs, but
Banana publishing this in his own video, right? I guess so, but
it just feels weird that he's gonna like he can, you know, muster
the same amount of outrage for everybody. >> I mean, like
>> maybe it's not weird. I don't know. I I feel like it's
weird to just blame bad on Panata and not mention the
>> They're going to treat this like a joke, but if you
if you feel comfortable with whatever details you feel comfortable
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> Um I imagine that was really stressful.
So like you've spent probably better part of a year planning
for this event to happen. you're really close to the wedding
day. Um,
and
in a lot of cases, like this type of ceremony really means like
a lot to the bride. Um, and then you have to sit her down and
tell her what's going on. Like, can you talk about what that
conversation was like and how that >> I don't want to get
into like those >> No. Yeah. Not specific. Yeah, that's
fine. Yeah. >> The point The point is it just sucked. Like
it it was chaotic,
>> dude. This is like uh Oh, this is like um this is like
those Destiny DMs, man.
Oh, I don't want to. It's like those Destiny DMs where the person's
talking about how they were like insulted. Destiny's like, "Oh,
I just want to come inside of you." Whatever the he was say,
right? Dude, have a little decorum. This guy just had his wedding
docs like a little while ago and you're you're sitting here like,
could you tell me what that was like? How did it feel? Do you
feel like you were in danger?
Don't worry about it sounding like I'm stroking it right now.
Okay. But could you tell me a little bit? Could you give me some
details on like how that felt? Could you tell me how that felt
for you? >> There was a lot of planning that had in logistics
that had to change to like communicate with >> Did your
wife cry? Did your wife cry when you talked about like like how
you might have to change the wedding venue? Did she cry? >> All
of these different people in the police stations like, "Hey,
this is what's going on." And it it's just a huge waste of everybody's
time. Like it's just a massive waste of everyone's time. the
whole point is to make you feel paranoid.
Um, even though like deep down like I knew none of these people
were going to [__] leave their mom's basement, right?
But, you know, it sucked. It wasn't It wasn't fun. It was annoying.
But, um, like luckily, just as a quick PSA,
actually, Willie getting docked was super I think doxing somebody's
wedding, the location, the time, the date, super gay. Uh, I felt
it was enough for me to take this guy who's done nothing but
like lie about me, make [__] up about me, and like
try to slander me to his audience, which I had a lot of adjacent
like overlap, right? It was enough for me to go, you know what,
I actually feel like some humanity for this guy, empathy for
this guy. He's done other too, which is like private talk about
it at some point, but he's like a total degenerate in like every
way. And I stopped and was like, "Dude, this really up." But
then he just started lying about what happened too after the
fact. like started lying about what where the like who the origination
was from and I've kind of just lost all patience with this guy.
>> Like we had people that were like really good and and
have dealt with stuff like this before like that were involved
and uh not just Ethan but my planner, you know, like the stations
have dealt with that, the venue had dealt with that. So it just
um everything ended up working out and going off without a hitch
and it was like the best day ever, man. Seriously. So you did
you guys did manage to have a good time despite that. You managed
to >> great. It was like the greatest day ever. Seriously,
it's like >> like that negatively impacting this really
special day for you guys was really upsetting for even though
I don't know you guys. Just like the concept of that happening
is something that I think is indicative of a culture that's like
>> you really
the internet dude.
Well, he had >> I was just I was looking at some chat messages
and it's like, "God damn it, hold on. I don't want to skip those
chat messages now." >> Lately, like I think that video
got like 200,000 views. >> What was the first video on?
Do you >> Oh, we're we're not here. We're further forward.
Trying to figure out where we >> I've I've kind of rolled
around in the mud with various toxic communities. >> Not
here. Just a little further forward. If somebody could go back
to the bottom, >> call them a liberal or call them.
>> Oh, you won't be able to see it. Never mind. and uh
just try and discredit like that that's always the game plan.
Um I started getting like really heavily attacked by these people.
Um did you have a similar situation there? I mean I >> what
ends up happening is that the lie gets repeated so often that
their
>> black pill kind of thing >> that's said >> yeah
he thinks that windmills cause cancer like he said this is a
lot of cases like this type of ceremony really
>> like really good and and have dealt with stuff like
this before like that we're >> and uh not just Ethan but
my planner you know like might be the best wedding to ever happen
>> there we go we're back for even though I don't know
you guys just like >> god Sorry, this is what I wanted
to highlight and it like clicked way back in the VOD. My like
mouse stuck on here and it clicked way back in the VOD. Okay,
so somebody asked like what was going on and this guy like all
of the people who articulate what they think happens in this
situation just give this uh this response which is like well
actually it's like cross-pollination and they reference KF and
like they organize in Discords or sub Discord. It's like they
just keep going through the exact arguments someone else makes
with no evidence and they think that that's like like they're
Hutch's audience is actively engaging in the exact thing he is
purporting to denounce on stream. Like they're directly engaging
in it, right? We're just going to make up a lie and then we'll
just repeat the lie over and over until other people believe
it. But they're actively engaging in it. >> like the concept
of that happening is something that I think is indicative of
>> and this just closed. Are you serious? What a dog website,
dude. I just clicked on the video and it closed the video.
>> I'm It's definitely going to change how I go about
>> Oh my god, I'mma lose it. I'mma lose it. It's I think
they save place though.
>> Nope, not at all. >> Of a culture that's like
really rotten in online spaces. Um I think you can be really
blunt and have disagreements with people and even ne, you know,
you don't have to be nice to them. You can be mean sometimes,
but once we start graduating into this situation where you got
to worry about logistical concerns for security for your wedding
because of this, then I think it's like really escalated to a
point where, you know, I'm just I'm I'm afraid that something
is really bad is going to have to happen for people to understand
the seriousness of these kinds of things. U I hope >> it's
literally it's it's the point where it's no longer online banter
at that point and you're just like affecting people's real lives.
Yeah. And like that sucks. Like that's not I don't Yeah. I I
don't understand how >> So surely these guys will all totally
all totally distanced. Dude, it's so
Destiny. Sorry. Willie was taking narratives directly from Destiny
while he's talking about how bad it is to do. How doxing is like
actually evil? How the is this possible? How can you be such
a disingenuous rat? Like it's so gross.
He literally took all of his narratives for the video that he's
talking about on this stream from Destiny directly after Destiny
had doxed a bunch of people. Like, how how the can you do this
and not feel like a complete
>> This is like cuz this is something that I get like they're
weaponizing for their side right now and it probably feels like
kind of good like oh yeah, we're with them. But like dude, at
any point that could turn on you. It's like you you're the rules
of the game you're calling for to like to be changed here is
like incredibly dangerous. >> Hey, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. Okay, hold on. Is uh is Quan here right
I don't know if Queen is still watching. Willy's kind of laying
out sort of this hypothetical like, hey, if you have this standard,
this this would be really bad. I don't think you're thinking
about how this standard could be applied in a different direction.
It's almost like he might have watched something at this point
and >> and I don't think like any creator online no matter
what kind of content you create
should be should be asking for it to go there.
>> How does be I I don't understand. So does YouTube just
not take action against this guy? Like I I don't >> So
I think he blurred the video. So they just thought like like
YouTube thought that was enough that he blurred that one little
part. Even though when he scrolls down it still shows it. He's
still splasting my name, saying my name to everybody, you know,
just YouTube doesn't care. And um
I don't know. Yeah, I don't know what to do there or why. But
>> do you do you feel a do do you feel a kind of reluctance
to cover certain topics in the future or are you going to keep
pressing on and just doing what you >> I'm No, man. I'll
just cover what I cover. I mean, I part of me is like stubborn
and feels like
I never want um I I will not give these people an inch cuz they're
so clearly in the wrong on this [__] And uh you know,
I'm going to keep like slamming it when um when they're being
like annoying or whatever, but like >> wow, just like Techone
pop the grape into your mouth. I'm going to keep farming them,
dude. Yeah. You know, I did just cry. I did just have like a
really traumatic But I'm just going to keep farming these guys,
guy, dude. Okay. I'm just going to keep barbing. >> The
other part of me like yeah that there's probably like a there's
a little thought in the back now of like will I want to deal
with this? What are what are the stakes right now in this thing?
>> So like I wish I could be brave and say >> oh
skip to the next one.
you know inviting people to things in the future and like
>> well I'm not I mean listen I'm not I'm not going to
judge you. changing some stuff, you know, like I don't want to
uh I don't want to exactly like set myself up for the same sort
of uh same sort of thing. Like if I throw a big a big like 10-year
anniversary, I'm probably going to be like, you know, let's not
talk about any doxers this week, you know? >> Well, certainly
making a video certainly making a video about be is like directly
directly confronting the situation. So I I hope for your case
it doesn't, you know, escalate further. >> No, no. I mean
now like let's face it, we're [__] here. Like it
can't get any worse. It just we're at this point. >> Yeah,
I guess we already passed the >> This guy. I'm not going
to go ahead and like what? Like if he's making money off of my
docs and posting a YouTube video with ads and and getting Patreon
subscribes. I'm going to make money off my docs. All right. It's
got to be fair, >> I I think that's fair. Yeah, that's
reasonable. I want to end this conversation with a question and
two compliments. And so the the question I want to ask you is
um you had that that debate with um Hassan, but you I think you
had said that you had no real like experience in debate. Um you're
not like the super political person. Uh but you ended up I think
like completely holding your own in that conversation. Uh were
you nervous going into that situation? Didn't it happen like
on the fly? Didn't Wasn't it like something? >> Yeah. Yeah.
Is that the >> You're like really like I can't believe
you had no preparation. You're not a political person. You just
like got to go in and and argue with Hassan. >> How did
you How did you manage that, man? How did you manage that [__]
>> Grocery store checking out my 2% milk. And he starts
like ramping on Twitter like, "Uh, get on here, debate me about
Israel Palestine." And I told him no. Um, and then he said, "Well,
it does." I was like, "I'll debate about you, not Israel Palestine."
And he said, "All right, fine. Do it. Willie no show." And I'm
like, "Oh, dude, he brought out the nickname. I got I got to
show up now." >> were you nervous going into it? >> I
was I was nervous about it, you know? But at the same time, like,
and I am not a good debater. I'm I honestly I think I'm running
like an IQ of like a B+, maybe like an 88% or some [__]
Like I'm not I'm not that smart. But the fact is like you don't
>> are too generous. You >> don't have to be a good
debater and you don't have to be that smart if you're just like
objectively right. Well, it was really what I it was it was I
feel like it was really hard for him to make any kind of case
because I thought the whole point of the debate was to talk about
your video, but then he was claiming that he never watched the
video, which I just don't believe for the record, but like how
do you how do you how do you watch the video? >> Yeah.
How do you debate someone about the contents of a video without
watching the video? Like, >> oh, you would just say, "Hey,
I know you made a video on me. Do you want to make the same arguments
you made in the video?" And then I'll like I'll talk about it
cuz I cover this topic extensively. So you can just come on and
and talk about it like like hey you made some affirmative arguments
about me in your video. Do you want to come and make those affirmative
arguments and I'll defend them on stream? Seems like incredibly
easy to do actually is what's confusing about that? How is that
confusing? Willie won so hard all the breaks they had to take
for Willie to go back and watch his bro. There's no way that
Willie like literally just was like hold on let me go rewatch
the video so I can understand the arguments I was making. There's
no shot that that's what the There's no shot that that's what
that debate is.
There's no way. Come on. >> How the [__] are
you supposed to do that? Just like that was just so absurd that
I felt like it gave you the upper hand in that conversation.
>> We did it. And then every time I I would get to the
point where it's like, "See how you're this up. See how you're
doing that wrong." He would just be like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, all right. Next topic." It's like, "Okay, so like
I mean I don't know." >> Yeah. Guess we'll take that one
as that's probably as good as we're ever going to get for him.
You know, the whole point of Hassan, like the minute he realized
like he was on the back foot of that debate and uh I actually
had like receipts and was was documented on this stuff, uh he
just started yelling at me and like name calling the whole time
and
>> doing what he calls like debate
or
Well, that I I felt like that took balls to step into that space
because that guy covers politics for like 8 to 12 hours every
day and you covered >> It doesn't take balls when the core
thesis of your videos is this guy's a disingenuous who couldn't
argue his way out of a paper bag who has no ability. He's like
totally disingenuous. He's lied about a whole bunch of stuff
and I can prove it. That's the content. That's the content he
made, right? You can't say he's super brave to step in and give
that exact same take to somebody that's not super brave. It's
literally like the bare minimum >> drama. You're not a
super political person. So I >> debates about as much as
me though. Hutch. Like let's be fair. The debate experience is
probably even >> he he certainly does it less these days.
>> Always debated somebody that wasn't like a 16-year-old
Israeli kid. >> So that the I want to end the conversation
with a compliment. The beard. Good luck, bro. That's an upgrade
for you, man. I I I want to see like an even thicker beard.
>> Like I want to see like >> try, dude. >> Let
it let it >> come at me for my small chin. So the best
part about growing a beard is boom, you you hide that.
>> The male version of makeup. >> It's a hack for
like 90% of dudes just grow out the beard. But yeah, >> it
is. Dude, it's nice.
>> Well, thanks for coming on. I'm glad to hear that your
wedding um that you guys were still able to enjoy it. It was
the best day ever. uh the thought of them like ruining >> people
from like uh you know every every background coming out and saying
like yeah that's insane and um no thanks guys. All right I'll
see you around. Pleasure meeting you Hutch. >> Hey take
it easy man. Crazy man. That's
I even if you don't like someone you know even if you have like
a personal grievance with someone like that that crowd has with
him. I don't understand why you have to. >> He's about
to say the exact thing I did and he's going to prove why it's
pointless. Okay. Why it's totally pointless to do it right. He's
going to say exactly. I don't understand why nobody tries to
like lower the temperature or call that [__] out.
I don't understand why nobody does that. I don't I just don't
get it, man. Why does nobody ever do that? Oh, I'm going to lose
it. sacrifice your humanity and celebrate something like him
having to hire security
for his wedding. Like I don't care how much I dislike someone.
If I see someone that has to go through some kind of real world
consequence like that, I'm going to put my pettiness aside and
be like, "Yeah, that's up." And it just seems like these people
think it's just a joke.
And uh it very much reminds me of the CPS stuff like this graduating
to a degree where there are these real life consequences for
um for this kind of harassment and uh behavior online.
Yeah, that's like absolutely disgusting. I'm pretty sure you
would like totally if Hutch is willing to join me arm in- arm
and disavow and totally disconnect from never watch the content
of just totally mute out anybody who's ever done stuff like this.
I'm I'm ready. Okay, Hutch, I'm ready to stand there with you.
Okay, it's just totally unacceptable. And so, you know, good
on good on Willy Mack for just confronting it and just making
a video about it because Be is
deranged
and uh it wouldn't shock me if he escalated even more after this
video. Um,
it's just really up. It's just it's unbelievably up. Matt, hi.
Thank you so much for the tier one membership. Bad company with
$5. It's these tankies plan to create a chilling effect for people
like you. Glad people like Ethan. No, they just make things up
or or it's like random chat people. But even then it's like dude
even then it's like yeah there are people who are edgy and will
laugh and and make jokes about like Willy's IDF wife and
but there's just clearly a line and the line is you can say funny
things or you can you can say unhinged things but the line is
like when you're actually trying to invoke or force or enable
IRL like actual harassment of people that's like a nice neat
clear line that I think everybody can obey and everybody can
stand behind but it doesn't it doesn't matter. because you've
not Hutch explicitly, but a bunch of people have created an environment
where they're going to totally validate somebody who is willing
to say, "Well, if you laugh at those jokes, you're the same as
the people doxing.
They've totally validated that environment. They're the ones
who are incentivized and and trying to create an environment
where doxing is normalized, right? Because they're trying to
say, well, if you laugh at like really up jokes about people,
that's actually the same as doxing. That's like the same thing.
And you should be doxed and that's okay if you get doxed. is
defensive doxing cuz you laughed at something really up. You
laughed at how disgusting this guy's. Oh, you need to be doxed.
You need to be doxed right >> And Willie Mack are fighting
back. Keep up the good work. >> I mean, I'm watching Ethan
announce new
>> Oh, also for anybody wondering, people are like, "Wait,
how does how do people watch Hutch? Why are people watching Hutch?"
It's like, dude, listen. You got Hutch or you got like food shops
right now. Those are like the the two options for DG adjacent
or or counterpoints. These are like the three options for DG
adjacent like viewers and DG adjacent
This these are like the options. And Hutch is stupid. Hutch makes
really bad arguments, but like Hutch is I I think Hutch is like
infinitely better. Or Tom. Well, they don't really consider Tom
anymore. Fortunately, Tom's kind of worked his way out of the
uh he's just worked his way out. All right. for these people
that have smeared me and lied about me. And I can't help but
feel
>> no, I don't know what that is. >> Very curious
to see how those lawsuits play out.
Um, Goku with 11 months, Moond Dog with the primer, Ace with
$5, Willie. Okay, I think we're uh we're done with